hello Jordan c8 a stubby announce what's
going on some kind of chronic sinus I'm
good man how are you doing
Jordan I'm Welker is the well he's the
host in the in the know the head head
captain of the art of charm not just a
podcast but a whole movement and company
and lifestyle and and and the whole deal
yeah I mean you know technically AJ is
the CEO oh but that's good though
because you don't want that job people
who start businesses think they want
that job so they put it on their
business card from Vistaprint and then
you finding themselves yeah and then you
find out all of the things you have to
do as a CEO and you're like wow this
sucks
so you just the guy that gets to talk
about it and yeah the the figure for the
company is better to be the faces
becomes much better much in my opinion I
think AJ really likes to you and he's
better at it than I would be for sure I
would have driven us into bankruptcy
years ago now didn't they compare you to
like maybe not even accurately but to
like a pickup artist type of thing or
people talked about like in Paris was
like magic from vh1 what's meant by
mystery me really mystery so a long time
ago yeah we started off like hey you
know this body language stuff is really
cool it's really good for dating and
networking and then then that was before
all of that stuff started so then that
book the game came out a couple years
after we sort of see a very good book
and I Neal's a good friend of mine and I
was like oh this is going to be good for
everybody and then it was great for a
few years and then it that show on vh1
came out it was like wow Eric cape and
paint your fingernails the girls will
respond exactly it became a freakin
circus and then lost immediate
immediately lost all credibility
you don't pay him to show that wreck the
credibility that um it was partially the
show but then also mostly the riff raff
that the show had brought in right so it
was it went from look you know there's a
lot of guys out there that want to learn
body language and nonverbal
communication to I can decode women by
dyeing my hair pink and talking dryer
memes and it's like okay I don't want
and you don't want to be associated with
that it's like imagine you're you're in
college and you sell like really
high-end wheat or something like that
nowadays it's legal imagine you're in
California you sell really high-end weed
and some other guy who sells like dirty
crack is like oh yeah I'm into business
too and you're like
not really making my thing look bad
you're ruining yeah well I'm doing
exactly yeah like and you can't be like
oh I'm the good drug dealer so we were
just like I'm out rebrand we're done so
he would show up with like pink hair and
all these weird things I called peak
hockey and I guess you people be
interested in ooh he wear like like a
velvety cat in a hat style like weird
fabric hats and he literally one of them
would wear a cape and and like velvet
pants and stuff and and and their idea
was that well if you were just confident
in the most ridiculous clothes that
looks like you bought it like a
Renaissance Faire
yeah then like everything that like a
super nerd would wear thinking it was
cool but if you were confident in it
then women would just respond in droves
and they probably do they probably do
respond to confidence in you know to a
certain degree of course of course women
respond to confidence the people in
general respond to confidence the trick
the thing that they had that worked for
them was that when you're on Hollywood
Boulevard and these three stretches of
clubs where tourists from other
countries go to like hang out and see
Hollywood sure you're getting attention
and if you lie to enough women some of
them will believe you and then you can
be like look at all these beautiful
women I hang out with and you can put
photos of that on your social media
right but at the end of the day Ori
Feldman's angels yes it is very it's
very adjacent to that type of thing but
at the end of the day you have to ask
yourself do you want to be that person
because right pretty weird and freaky
and not cool and here's what I think it
I'm when it comes to meeting women I
stink at cold calling like if I want to
meet somebody out of like I do a set and
they see me after the show there's
something to talk about even there if
we're not gay it gives you a little bit
of status right like they know that
you're worth talking to because you were
the guy that was on stage well yeah but
there's also a common thing to discuss
was the experience we just had right
there ah hey I don't want you hon
Pacific no but you know did something to
talk about but as far as just walking up
to a girl on a store or I mean [ __ ]
horrendous at it I everybody
communicability I can't do it it's an
awkward situation in general yeah so and
there's all kinds of things that you
could read on the internet from some of
these guys were just talking about that
would maybe help with that but here's
the truth it's so much better and so
much easier and so
much more comfortable and so much more
reliable and consistent to just build a
bigger social circle of people that know
who you are through that same
situational confidence that you have why
bother being like it's a circus trick to
be able to approach every girl that you
like and and start up a conversation and
be able to do that it's great but it can
take years of work into what end are you
trying to I mean you're just trying to
get laid all the time maybe you know
then it's great but you can still do
that inside you work at a clubs people
love you your comedy is on fire why why
be like all right I'm going to handicap
myself and take all that away start from
zero at a grocery store why well you
know you that's a good question
but you see if you're out happy to be
somewhere there's like somebody you want
to meet you never know where you're
going to be when you meet some that's
true we'll never know the art that Jim
Norton has created doesn't bring you the
most desirable of people that's a good
point you know the woman I'm meant to
marry may not show up at one of my shows
and she made Google me and go [ __ ] this
guy yeah so it's like I talked to
somebody who's not to lay with me that
might actually help yeah I think that
that you you maybe on the stones in
there but my friend he met his wife when
we were in law school actually and he
goes I just don't know to go over there
and say to her and I just go and like
look man if you just go up there and
tell her that you thought she was pretty
but you didn't know how to start a
conversation it sounds terrible but this
guy already was really well put together
so he doesn't have to have anything
clever to say and I think a lot of guys
we think okay my first impression is
it's got to be this clever cool thing
but our first impressions are always
made non-verbally and if you want to
test this for yourself just go walk
outside anywhere and you'll make
judgments like tall threatening
attractive overweight like your bridge
the same woman I want to [ __ ] yeah yeah
this is all those are they're all
wrapped into one you make these
judgments and they're all done
non-verbally that person that you're
judging doesn't walk up and go I'm
threatening because I'm a minority right
that's you in my face
I walk by people just get [ __ ] that guy
you know I mean yeah I just look at it
and you look at guys oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah sure Troy and I will literally sit
down at lunch somewhere outside and just
watch people walk by and just go can you
believe all these [ __ ] jerk off like
that guy's a jerk off that guy's a jerk
off because you can get word to that
lady
you're welcome to go in to scold uh hey
I think you're pretty I mean it that's
not really what I was getting that with
this what are you getting that way yeah
yeah Zee snazzy jumper yeah yeah
hey clucks why don't you come hang out
in my hole huh what do you think of that
50% of the time it works percent of the
time I think I think the nonverbal stuff
really is we're at that really that's
the most important by far and there's
something that we teach at AOC at art of
charm and on the podcast that is called
the doorway drill and this is to just
get the non verbal stuff handle because
we know that's how your first impression
is made
so essentially unless you're driving
right now which a lot of people are
stand up straight chest up chin up
shoulders back you don't exaggerate you
know none of this like power posing
bullcrap like right I Tony Robbins or
whatever just open positive body line
body language if you remember what that
looks like and you do it every time you
walk through a doorway it'll become your
default habit and the way that you do
that is you put a post-it note in the
doorway otherwise you're just going to
forget after you hear this I've been
trying to make my posture my posture is
such [ __ ] yeah and yeah and I've been
trying to make a conscious effort but
the more you think of it the more you
remind yourself to stand up straight I
just don't have back issues you lost me
a little bit on that you don't want to
have back issues you don't care about
anything else you smile baby I know it
says confidence I'd stolen a back UT so
I don't like what you do for a
chiropractor you guys don't do a
chiropractor nervous no I can I can
adjust you guys later if you want well
you're more confident when you're
standing up straight they say when you
you know you just well also the way that
since we know that we judge other people
by the way they look if you have open
upright positive and open body language
that makes you look confident and
friendly people judge you that way right
and then that's an advantage already
that nonverbal in first impression is an
advantage already and then of course
when when that's consistent when people
consistently judge you that way you
start to act a little bit differently
which then changes the way that you
behave entirely so you don't have to
like fake confidence that's kind of BS
right you can actually have come you're
supposed to actually have confidence and
the way that you show it is non-verbally
not through having something clever to
say so like in the personal approach you
what were you thinking just going wow
check out how straight my back is that's
a bad rule I had yeah you know what just
party for you how you can work yeah
I'm yeah I have no subluxation
whatsoever which I think because I'm
thinking about as you talk about
nonverbal communication and things like
that is that whenever I'm in a new
situation or a situation that I don't
have an assigned task to do in that
moment I start to feel extremely uneasy
I never know what to do and I don't
start conversations with people because
I mean I don't know the lay of the land
yet I'm new to the thing and I feel like
I end up either just sitting somewhere
and obviously looking like I'm not
supposed to be there even if I am or
looking like well he has no idea what
he's doing or whatever it is I don't
know what to do yeah in those situations
with myself that's why people pull out
their phone right because they're like
feeling I'm I'm just sitting around
doing that remember when we didn't have
phones and it was even worse yeah I just
haven't pop lock just dancing that bad
bad strategy I mean habit I'll admit
some of the time when I'm just trying to
kill if I'm in that similar situation
well the first the first thing you want
to do that I like to do is is start
asking people questions and taking
control the conversation do you guys
have this skill as talk-show host where
you can just start controlling a
conversation it's kind of a superpower
right because you can start having
entertaining conversations pretty much
anywhere and people will fall into it
you're used to controlling a guess
you're used to controlling the flow of a
conversation huge superpower for the
rest of us that may be folks listening
that are not used to controlling a
conversation we go to our phones and
I'll admit half the time if I'm not
talking with somebody I'm staring at my
phone screen and that is off it is off
when I'm looking at just like the home
screen and I'm like okay so I started I
literally if I could count on
fingers and toes the amount of apps I've
downloaded just because I'm like this is
going to be heard when I have nothing to
do I'm going to look at this and it's
going to look like I'm doing something I
don't do that anymore obviously but I
spent years trying to figure out how to
look busy when I felt awkward I feel
like that's impersonal meaning people
because I believe very much in creating
relationships like I think that that's
how people do well in everything yeah
but if you're sitting there staring at
your phone you don't look like you're
ready for somebody to approach our
conversation of course not yeah
I don't recommend that strategy I'm just
saying I spent years and years doing
that because I used to be awkward as
help they're sometimes good in fact you
don't want to talk to anybody if you're
bored you don't want to talk to people
sometimes it's just to look at your
phone like look but what no eye contact
I don't want to communicate what do you
do if you actually want to be
constructive in a scenario like that do
you just bite the bullet and start a
commerce yeah
focus on so first thing I would say is
focus on one person especially if that
there's another person who looks like
they're on the periphery of the
conversation this is really good because
what a lot of people do when they feel
like awkward I'm on the outside of this
they try to talk to the whole group and
if you're on the periphery of a
conversation people are maybe ignoring
you because they don't know you or the
it you know deliberately or accidentally
then you might be ignored by more than
one person in the group in which case
you're trying to talk to the whole group
your status is just going to plummeting
yeah and it's even worse right you're
like hey guys should we go eat is
anybody hungry and nobody's answering
you're like god dammit I wish I hadn't
said that yeah now I look even worse so
I would recommend if you're awake I
would recommend focused on one person
the other person that looks like maybe
they're on the periphery just focus on
them and and ask them questions and
start getting answers from that person
because they'll be forced to interact
with you in a way yeah and then it'll
also sort of force them to open you up
to the rest of the group you can even
say something like hey if you don't know
the rest of the group you can system
them like hey how do you guys all know
each other and then that person can't it
would be very hard and awkward more
awkward for them to ignore that question
than to answer it
right but that may be annoying to them
though that's fine like if you're in the
middle of a real conversation and then
there's some guy on the outside just
trying to pepper in what are we talking
about yeah guys I wouldn't interrupt any
heavy conversation yeah if you're at
awake and somebody's sharing a story but
they're their uncle you know who's
recently passed you might not want to be
like hey are you guys hungry yeah you
want to against word um you went to
North Korea how many times we've been
four times why I know right now I look
at it and I'm like Holies are used to
want to go back out oh you know okay so
now what will you surprise that happen
and do you think that that guy possibly
stole that sign or is it could they have
them on video but it's not a really
clear video they don't true it's not a
very good know if it was him or if it
was not him really it looks like a white
guy oh just like me oh yeah the video
pretty clear I thought but I mean he
could have done I'm pretty sure that he
had the the poster on the other way I
don't think you have to die because you
solo pose right I've stolen posters
under I'm alive right so what why did
you go to North Korea so the first time
I went I was like oh this country's not
open to Americans I'm gonna go with my
friend so I went was my friend and then
I talked about it on the art of truant
podcast and a bunch of people were like
oh man I don't know you could go there
so I brought a bunch of show fans with
me and then I talked about that trip I
brought Neil Strauss actually I did and
then we talked about it on another
episode of the art of charm and then he
talked about on his blog and then we
brought another group of people and I
went again it was just to explore just
to see what yeah it was just tourism was
it scary no it was weird as hell because
it's like there's no stores there's
nothing to do there's no real nightlife
people are walking around in the dark
there's no streetlights like there's no
cars on these huge roads it's weird
really yeah so no stores you can't just
run out and grab something no so what if
you want something the hotel has a small
store that has stuff in it that you can
buy with you have to exchange Chinese
money you can't use the local money you
can't just get money from them and yeah
it's such a weird process it's so it's
so socialist right if you want to buy
something from the store you have to buy
it no till you can't leave the hotel
anyway without the guides in the box
right so say you want some water you go
down to that store and there's like 15
employees in a store because it's
communist right so yes or that one
person should work at there's 15 people
in there maybe like seven realistically
you go to one and you're like I want
these things and they're like don't
touch anything one person will grab what
you want they bring it to another person
and then they stand there and that
person's job is to like write down all
of the prices on all of the items and on
a ledger and then that person has
another person who takes that piece of
paper walks it over to a cashier you'd
pay the cashier she leaves and goes in
exchanges all the money comes back with
your change gives that the change and
the receipt to the other girl who goes
back to your stuff and puts it in a bag
and gives it to you it's literally one
person's job done by like 7:00 or if you
go for a week there yeah I went there
for a week each time is it boring I mean
it sounds boring ODI guess you get to
see why they want you to say it's weird
it's weird it's not boring because
you're like what the hell the whole time
but
after a week you're like okay I need
food that isn't clearly just you know
canned old fish or like you know gross
old recycled food because you'll you'll
go to a restaurant that you eat at the
hotel every time so you go to the hotel
and you'll have like a fish that you
don't want to eat because it's a whole
fish and it looks kind of gross sure and
the next day they serve it and the next
day they serve it and you know so
eventually we're like hmm they're really
big on this fish so one of one of our
friends took a chopstick and like fold
it up we'll need underside of the fish
and jam the chopstick in there and made
like a little hole and then the next day
we were like okay now we can tell if
it's the same fish and we lifted it up
and sure enough there was a chopstick
hole 7 renamed fish three days if you
don't eat it they'll reheat it and give
it to you the next day not even heated
hold-hold fish did you get caught did
you get done you're kim jeong-hoon at
all or no so i'm speaking actually yeah
but not like I didn't go up in like
double high-five chest-bumping or
anything like that yeah what was it a
public rally
it was a huge parade with military
parade anything is the first time that
he's ever spoken to the public I think
so huge deal we weren't bringing you're
falling I'm always wearing I have so
many dirty pictures and things on my
phone did you wipe your phone because
the North Koreans say I want to look at
your phone you have to show them at the
time you had to leave your phone locked
up at the airport you couldn't you
couldn't bring it in the airport Beijing
or trying to know in in Pyongyang North
Korea they take your phone and they give
you a receipt so you don't have it
anyway
but they gave it to you and you relieved
it yeah they give it to you when you
leave yeah okay so you have you know
outfit that you're going to get it back
the first time I was like I don't know
they might not keep yeah and be like Oh
an iPhone now we'll just hang on to this
it's valuable but they gave it back the
second time and of course after that I
was used to it and then the fourth time
I want they let me bring my phone in
they do yeah but it doesn't work what
kind of camera service
no service yeah what kind of camera you
keep like a portable camera to take
pictures you can bring a camera but the
lens has to be under a certain amount of
millimeters I forget what it was but you
can't it can't be a telescopic lens it
just can it can't have GPS on it because
they don't want you marking photographs
of things and then like where they are
sure which is dumb because they have to
know that we have satellites that know
where everything is it could possibly
see from above ground anyway so they
don't want you taking like long you know
military photos we're just paranoid
yeah they're paranoid it was cool though
because you go to the DMZ you know
between North and South Korea and there
was a fire going in the middle it's
there's a sort of kilometer long stretch
which is just like land mines where
there was a fire going some of the land
mines are blowing up because the fire
this brush fire was going and I was able
to get South Korean cell phone service
and call my parents and send some
pictures to Instagram and upload some
stuff to Facebook because you're like
right there and our tour guide was like
hey don't use your phone or if you do
just you know go over there because the
soldier is looking for people who are
doing this it's against the rules I
think and I thought that was pretty cool
because our tour guide was like you
probably shouldn't be doing that I don't
have any concrete information but even
the people who live and work there they
kind of know like pretty much everything
is against the rules right yeah it's the
opposite if you're in North Korea when
you did that yes
now when you cross is that room that
they have in between the North and the
South what it's like realistic and it
you kind of go in there and there's a
lot like you're on the south side here
and the north side here right do people
ever just step over into the north and
step back like in that room you can go
anywhere in that room oh you can you can
but when you go in there from the north
side I've only been there from the north
side so those are those blue Hut's that
are like the UN runs those I guess and
they're right over the border in the DMZ
it's where the DMZ touch that's where
the soldiers are standing there staring
each other each other and also so you
can go in those rooms when you go in
there on the north side the South Korean
soldiers they stand there and when the
when South Korean tourists go into those
buildings the North Korean military just
goes back into their headquarters
they're just not around for it they
don't know why nobody's been able to
explain it so when you go inside that
blue hut like where they can't give
messages to the South Korean maybe
something like that yeah maybe something
like that and when you're in the hut the
North Korean soldiers will stand at the
at the border of South Korea by the door
so you can't just walk out wait you
would say that yeah I'm sorry so imagine
there's a blue that blue hot right yeah
imagine I go you're on the North Korean
side sorry the South Korean side under
soldier the door is next to you and
you're standing there like this and I'm
like what are you afraid we're going to
leave we came here on a tour and you're
like no it's for your own protection and
I'm thinking I'm not worried about an
American snatching me out of this blue
hut and sending me back to Detroit I'll
be okay
but they're worried about that
supposedly but really it's in theory it
so that people who are North Korean
soldiers probably so the other soldier
doesn't run out because if you look at
the way the soldiers are set up and this
is just speculation from a lot of people
the South Korean soldiers in the
Americans they're looking North the
North Korean soldiers are facing each
other and so the prevailing theory is
that the North Koreans are looking at
each other so that you know if I'm
looking at you I know you're not going
over because I'll shoot you first and I
said where's the South Koreans like I
ain't going over there man are you crazy
yeah nobody's thinking I didn't know the
North Koreans looked at each other they
do do you think to yourself like in
hindsight if they had if the wrong
person had seen me use my phone over
there at the wrong time they could have
just thrown me in jail yeah in theory
yeah in theory right I didn't think
about it at that time obviously I was
just because this is before all this
stuff happened right this is years ago I
went there probably the last time with
at least four years ago so even before
Rodman was over there I went right the
week after Rodman was there right yeah
actually the same week rod knows there
but I did not see him oh you had a
basketball now did not go for the basket
I did get invited to the game though I
missed it by a week yeah because you got
to get a visa like you know I couldn't
just be like oh you know what let me
change my trip dates room yes so you go
through China right you go through China
yeah go through Beijing China you you
can take Air Koryo which is a North
Korean airline flying a Russian plane
you can fly Air China trying to probably
safer I would say so yeah
but what do you do for like for like you
you get there and they take you out and
show you like monuments and stuff like
that yeah they show you the weirdest
stuff so you'll see if in it sounds
boring when I explain it but I assure
you it's not you'll see a flower
exhibition which sounds stupid right
like who cares about a flower exhibition
and then you realize it's the largest
flower exhibition in the world and
they're making like huge ak-47s out of
different colored flowers that are so
intricate that if you stood far enough
away it would just look like a giant
ak-47 but it's made out of frickin
flowers and they're making portraits of
people and it's like each flower is kind
of a pixel it's amazing really really
cool is there any kind of like you think
like organized crime element there it
seems like there must be variable things
that they want there is yeah there's
like the troops in the street or like is
there any type of a bootleg yeah like if
you're walking around you get mugged
yeah that you will not get mugged
because you're with
and minders and stuff like that who are
you know their tour guides and things
like that and you're kind of kept away
from most people but there are stories
Chinese people have a little bit more
freedom of movement there so if you look
at Chinese blogs and things like that
there are people who are like I got
mugged in North Korea how did you get
mugged well I went into a market because
I was there doing a business deal so I
was with what they're still with minders
but they can kind of go wherever some
Chinese have more free they have a
little more freedom it spreads because
they're able to do business there so a
business minder is not like a tour guide
you know they might just be like a local
security guy who's there to keep an eye
on them so they can kind of walk around
in the security guy will follow them
around and they'll go into a market and
people are saying yeah they got mugged
there but there are there are a lot of
weird reports of people smuggling cell
phones across the border or smuggling
DVDs across the border smuggling
everything people especially can go over
the river when it's frozen and and I
even went on a boat into North Korea
from China that was the might have been
the fourth time I took a boat in there
and the Chinese people are like they're
just like American tourists only even
even more not giving a rat's ass about
anything so they're like don't take any
pictures and so these Chinese guys are
like I don't give a [ __ ] about that and
they're taking the pictures of all these
North Korean guard posts on the side of
the river and I remember the the Chinese
boat captain just kept yelling kept
yelling don't take pictures don't take
pictures people just kept doing it and
finally one of the North Korean guards
took his rifle out and raised it up and
aimed it at the boat and then like the
other guards on the on the guard post
they all trained their guns right on the
boat and our boat captain just like
gunned it away and was screaming on the
intercom like put the cameras away they
will actually shoot you no and that's
like the Chinese are worried about the
China because they have a different
relationship with North Korea that they
wouldn't be as they don't North Korea's
money problems with China they don't
they don't but the people who work there
in the guards and stuff they just don't
care you know they don't care there was
some fishermen that went to take I guess
they probably went to take it honestly
probably to take a dump on the other
side of the river they were in the river
and they went they went over there to
you know probably untangle a net or take
a crap or something they got shot they
set foot on the land and the guard just
came down and machine gun the whole boat
and everybody in it I mean thank God
it's the one good thing that's come of
all this like people are finally
realizing that nobody over there gives a
[ __ ] like nobody is playing around they
tell you not to do something and they
just shoot though just shoot whoever
they say that's why I would never know I
would go over there no I I now I'm like
what the hell was I even thinking yeah
you know cuz that kid who went there
everyone's like what an idiot but
theoretically before he went there the
worst thing that happened was they
detained some old guy for like a week in
the hotel for talking a ton of smack
about the Korean War because he was in
it right but before that there was
really nothing else going on there were
a couple religious guys were handing out
Bibles that obviously got in trouble but
they take offense to jail or sent home
they get sent to jail a couple of them
but they were handing out Bibles they
worked in North Korea they were doing
subversive stuff like they were handing
out they were talking about Kim Jong
Un's not the real you know there's a God
and he's different and they were
proselytizing this kid just stole a
poster when he was drunk completely
understandable thing to do maybe he
could have got you know thrown in jail
overnight but today I mean he got killed
there what do you think and the guy who
killed him was probably just some guy in
some garden jail supply the government I
didn't say beat him to death but they'll
probably just kicking his ass in jail
where he tried to hang himself or
choking him yeah there wasn't there
wasn't whatever what trauma they would
do is they're off somehow somehow well
maybe they waterboarded him I don't know
a lady cuz really things like yeah but I
mean that was kind of a bad PR move for
them I'm definitely yeah that was a bad
move it makes me think that there's just
like no oversight about what's going on
like oh yeah we got this American in
there and they're like alright well
let's put some sadistic mofos in there
with them and it's like okay oh crap
that happened we should send them home
for health care and then he dies and
they're like ah [ __ ] we shouldn't uh we
should probably more botulism yeah after
them yeah I googled it it's it's really
dangerous they'll believe that well it
feels like something has to change there
though it's been so bad for so long and
Kim jong-un just seems like he just
doesn't seem competent to run the the
country cuz he's like a little fat kid
like that is thirty right maybe thirty
now but do you think he killed his
brother was that what it was his brother
his brother uncle Donald uncle
well no no I mean with the poison on the
airport oh yeah definitely
that was his brother yeah that's right I
forgot about that I don't
I forgot about that that's definitely
what happened I don't know why they
would do that either
I guess because that guy was talking
about how much North Korea was a dump
and like I didn't want to run the place
and he was also potentially a threat to
him because maybe maybe they were
there's probably all kinds of weird
stuff happening inside North Korea right
like factions and all so it's possible
that somebody reached out them from the
military was like look we're going to
get rid of your fat brother he's a
useless piece of crap you come back run
the country we'll do all the work and
then Kim jong-un got wind of that was
like I'm gonna admit this one in the bud
yeah paranoid about it just parent yeah
or or nothing happen and he's like this
is the thing that could happen you know
he's drinking his Hennessy every day and
he's like this could this could happen
get him
she's getting more and more paranoid
more and more seriously yeah just to try
to maintain because he obviously likes
his power to be absolute and he wants
everybody to see him as a god and it
becomes very especially when you're as
flawed a person as he is yeah it becomes
very easy for somebody to call you out
or or for the for the people's opinion
to all of a sudden be enlightened to the
fact that you're not a god you're just a
dude yeah a fat overweight dude with a
limp like yeah kind of shitty dude
yeah just like some and who came out of
nowhere it's not like he grew up there
was groomed to be the leader you didn't
showed up one day yeah as the new leader
all the military guys were like what the
hell direct seemed like such a
frightening place to live like oh yeah
so much pressure to not make a mistake
to not make to not say the wrong thing
like it's you that there's no humanity
there I mean there's got to be some but
it's you know there's just nothing fun
do people go out to night clubs there do
they go out dancing I mean do they I've
heard that yeah our tour guides talked
about that they go out and they meet
people and they go out dancing they go
to bars and stuff like that which I
thought I thought was pretty cool I
remember asking one of our female tour
guides where she met boys and she goes
at the library of course oh yeah I was
like and of course where do you meet
girls I was like not at the library Wow
okay so that you have some kind of
social life yeah I mean I guess so I
think it's probably high leads it's such
a weird contradiction right because
Society for them is everything and yet
everyone's afraid of each other because
they're all reporting on each other so
it's kind of like you have this secret
police and everyone's reporting on each
other and confessing all these imaginary
crimes and you
that they don't have material comforts
they are supposed to be like everyone
play for the same team and you know get
out there and move the country for it
and that's like the whole rhetoric that
you hear and yet you could be dating
some but you could be married to
somebody you could be like this place is
such a [ __ ] and then she's like ah
cos I got a telling you now and you're
gonna go die yeah yeah that's it and I
can't trust anyone can't trust anybody
no you were voted for magazine said that
you were one of the 50 best relationship
builders in the world and put you
alongside of Tony Robbins and Oprah as
one of the 25 people to change your life
like what what makes that determine you
do that they go like wow this guy is
like better great class yeah Fiser
I think what it is is a ya love somebody
and somebody who was works at Forbes was
probably like I like this guy show and
that was I was probably a whole criteria
there but success magazine that had that
25 people that will change your life
that came out and I didn't even know
about it
really I didn't even know about it no I
somebody shared it with me and was like
congratulations and I was like okay so I
emailed their their PR or whatever you
want to call it anyway hey can I get a
copy of this magazine so they mailed it
and yeah there was like Oprah Tim
Ferriss me and Tony Robbins and a bunch
of other you know Les Brown all these
these kind of celebrity folks it was
pretty cool but it's I have no idea how
they make that determination what do
they attribute it to like what do they
say okay this is what Jordan says that
we think is it was all about the
relationship building stuff the
networking stuff and a lot of the
nonverbal communication stuff that we
teach on the show and at our boot camps
in LA so they based a lot of it on that
and I think they're they're also
focusing a lot on the fact that some of
the a lot of our clientele like you
mentioned before there there's a lot of
people ten years ago that came through
because they wanted it they're like oh
I'm single I need to meet women now we
get like the Green Berets intelligence
agencies Israeli Special Forces British
Special Forces so I think they went and
they were like oh this isn't some BS
right picking artists nerd camp
yeah excel you when you do these
workshops like you said it's not just a
podcast you also have workshops and you
actually work with people individually
maybe it's different because people are
paying to be a part of it but do you get
people that just don't listen because
I've found that like
and maybe it's just I don't know if it's
generational but like I've talked to
multiple people right who are trying to
get involved in this business the
entertainment business whatever it is
and like as I'm talking to them I can
tell they're retaining more seven to ten
percent of what I've said really that's
a high I'm surprised as even that high
yeah because the rest of it is one ear
out the other
you could just see in the eye contact
that they know everything already and
I'm like and you're halfway through the
conversation realizing that you're
wasting your breath yeah for you because
that person might you might as well be
talking to the wall but how do I get my
own radio show man I'll be so cool and
then you start explaining and then
they're just over here because I now
because the answer isn't what they are
on now yeah if you said pick up the
phone dial seven the big all right I'll
do that
got it but because there's more steps to
it they're like oh this sucks yeah when
you start getting into the fact that
well the first year and then there's
this and then what yeah now you know
what I'm just going to I literally had a
conversation with somebody an intern
and it like it drove me crazy I don't
even know if they realized how
off-putting it was when I was like I was
talking to them and they were older they
had kids and they were interning and he
was like well yeah I want to kind of
follow in your footsteps I was like he
was like I wanna I want to you know
intern now and then go on to you know do
bigger and bigger things I'm like well
that's cool but I was like but how are
you gonna you got a wife and a kid like
how are you gonna support them in the
beginning and he goes why I'm just
playing on doing it twice as quick you
know
oh yeah a girl clan yeah why didn't I
think of that yeah well I should have
you know what you know I did I chose my
pace I should have been doing this when
I was like 25 yeah you know just for
some gasoline on the fire right right
he's I shoulda been cooking with gas
yeah I'm twice as fast do you deal with
that like people who are just like
you're like why did you sign up for this
you're not listening it's rare I mean I
yeah there's a couple I would say every
quarter there's probably one where and
you know what it's never some young guy
who's like I'm smart I know everything
it's always a doctor who's like 52 and
he's on his fifth wife or his business
is failing and he's like you know I
don't have to listen to you guys and
it's like
don't but you did sign up and fly all
the way here from Hawaii so you should
yeah why are you here if you want it and
a lot of times these guys will go this
is this ego thing that I'm doing right
now this is what's screwing me up and
I'm thinking great now we can move past
it and that nope that looks like I get
there just a victim to it how old are
they usually 50s okay yeah yes oh that's
probably part of it too I guess it's a
different set right at your 40s or 50s
you're probably set in your ways like
this is what I do
and then in like your 20s because you're
young dumb and full of [ __ ] you know
you're you're smarter than the room
anyway yeah yeah they don't get it yet
I'm gonna figure it out because you just
there's just opportunity in front of you
right right it's all it's all open road
yeah and I think that some of it is
because you're set in your ways and some
of it is probably like I don't want to
have to if I listen to this Jordan guy
who's 15 years younger than me yeah that
says something about me that I don't
like right and then so I don't want to
do that I want to I kind of want to come
to this this workshop so he tells me you
already got it dude you're so good this
man all right yeah I should come can I
actually learn from you yeah well
there's no confirmation I don't need to
change anything
exactly yeah what is this 30-day social
challenge the the AOC challenge yeah
that's a lot of little comfort drills
that are like some of them are really
small steps like making a video to
introduce yourself that's a no-brainer
for most people but a lot of people who
are more introverted they have a lot of
trouble with that some of it though has
to do with figuring out ways to apply
social pressure to people that doesn't
have real consequences so doing
something in public that's not not
embarrassing and certainly not illegal
and not going to damage your reputation
but maybe requires you to step way
outside your comfort zone and we ramp it
up every couple of days forty for
example yeah so one example was like
like laying down on a sidewalk and
taking a picture of your feets in and
other folks doing it or asking other
people to help you with that which is
not weird
I mean it's sorry it's weird but it's
not your people are going to be like
there's a mentally ill guy outside in
the lobby it's just strange but it looks
like a touristy thing to do and a lot of
people can't do it a lot of people
listening right now are like this is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard but when
they go to try it they'll go oh man I'm
getting stopped up at all these
different places and there's a ton of
different exercise you lay down and say
you stand out there and take a picture
of my seat yeah or or your sorry your
stent you're laying down taking a
picture of your feet but you either have
to get somebody else in it to help you
or you have to some of the more advanced
drills are like I need you to hold me up
while we do this and that's very that
can be really awkward having somebody
hold you up the thing is when people do
it there's like a 99% success rate
because if somebody was like hey this is
weird but can you hold me up while I
take a picture of this you'd probably be
like sure that's weird but I'll do it
yeah but most people they have so many
hang-ups when it comes to asking other
people for things or doing something on
their own and so we're the 30-day
challenge exposes all those little gaps
and let me give you some drills to work
on those things
so with this of the podcast use the
artists charm on the re charm calm the
art of charm on Twitter and of course
that same in the podcast which is hugely
successful so did this start like okay
this is what this is going to be or did
a clip into it when I worked here in New
York I used to be an attorney and I
worked at this law firm that doesn't
exist anymore I was doing a lot of
finance stuff done in World Financial
Center and the everybody there was
smarter than me and everybody there was
a hard worker and when I was in when I
was in high school in college well high
school anyway I was able to kind of
coast on like I hate saying natural
smarts because it sounds douchey but I
was I was smart enough to fake it
through classes in high school not no
big nobody accomplishment there College
though everybody was as smart as me but
they're all getting drunk so I could
outwork them same thing with Law School
so when I got to Wall Street I was like
oh [ __ ] I don't have a competitive
advantage anymore everybody's smart and
everybody's a hard worker I'm gonna get
fired they're going to figure out in a
blonde here
classic impostor syndrome sure and I'm
screwed and so I started asking some of
the partners what they suggested and
they're like you got to learn to bring
in clients you gotta learn networking
skills so I started working with my
business partner AJ on networking
relationship development getting people
to truck know like and trust you which
is the core of the art of charm getting
all those concepts down thinking that
okay if I work on this now then in five
years when all these other smart
naturally gifted kids and hard workers
realize oh crap I got to bring in
clients to make partner I'll already
have a huge advantage on these guys and
girls and so I decided to work on that
and that turned into when the market
went downhill we started doing the show
to talk about these concepts nonverbal
communication
to asian-influenced and things like that
when we started the show the show
started to take off I actually had a
show here at Sirius XM for a while until
I moved out to LA and that went up and
the economy went down so my legal career
basically was in the toilet which is
great because I didn't want it at that
point I want to work on AOC so did Ned
for body language stuff that there's a
body language stuff can be aha
see Sam's listening yes tell me more
what is uh what is something you look
for in a body language or something that
people look for what we're using is
indicative of a certain like hey this is
the person I can dominate it this is a
person I can't dominate yeah I mean it's
really it doesn't come down to dominance
because I think or yeah that's a good
example though because a lot of men
especially think in terms of dominance
and so they try to signal dominance so
that you've seen you guys have seen this
there's guys that are like I want a
signal that I'm comfortable in this
environment so they take up like way too
much space right and you're like HM
that's weird because that's classic
overcompensation so it means obviously
they're insecure in the space they don't
feel comfortable in their own skin so
that's actually very contrarian way to
look at it they're they're actually more
likely to be insecure in England they're
likely to react to certain things so if
you want to get somebody like that to do
something that embarrasses them which
this is sort of dark let a Dark Jedi
[ __ ] but if you want if you're in a
meeting with somebody and you want to
push that person's buttons because you
want them to lose clout in front of
other people you can poke that person in
such a way that it would insult whatever
sort of dominance hierarchy they think
they're in or that they want to be in
and they'll react emotionally and
they'll lose control so for example when
I was negotiating a lawsuit a long time
ago that was part of the Artic charm the
mediator was he was like well I don't
know which side I fall on yet you know
so we started pushing the button so this
other person who is negotiating with us
and he started to get really whiny and
he started to go like well you know I
just you guys are a bunch of a-holes and
the mediator was like okey-dokey I see
who the unreasonable party here is and
then we use that to go look this guy's
completely unreasonable and he's like
yeah I can see that now and we ended up
with a huge advantage in that particular
suit because we caused him to get
emotional which caused him to lose
control of his impression in the
image that he was trying to maintain is
this professional you know upright guy
so you could look at someone's body
language you can find out what the
buttons are to press on those people
that's a little bit dark we like to use
it obviously for good wherever possible
if I see somebody who looks
uncomfortable in a conversation I might
go all right I'm going to talk with that
person because then people who are
uncomfortable in a room they don't know
what to do with themselves they'll find
an affinity for you if you're like so
sure what's your story man you're kind
of quiet over there I and yeah so then
I'm making friends of this person who
felt left out before now feels included
that's a huge advantage later on or it
could be you realize you made a terrible
mistake because they're not talking to
anybody for a reason they're awful